what about that uh sugar shawn oh yeah
shout out to sugar shawn o'malley bro
like
and also uh shout out to chris moutinho
like that guy
had an amazing [ __ ] chin dude like
alien zombie dude
is that what he's calling himself so i'm
calling him yeah he should i mean the
guy
walked forward the entire time actually
hit up
uh o'malley and i was like dude what the
most impressive thing that happened
in that fight for me was your will
didn't get broken by this guy who kept
walking forward and talking [ __ ]
because that will happen a lot of times
the fighters when they start playing
like fighting against like the elite
level you see with boxers like
what happened with mike tyson mike tyson
tells the story about uh
the first time he just couldn't knock
out this big white guy right in his
amateur years
and he just couldn't knock him out and
he's used to just destroying every
single guy he thought he could have
knocked out he just started falling
apart in the ring he got like scared
he didn't know what to do in that moment
so it's like
sean experiencing that now not during a
title fight or not during a title
eliminator
or one of those now he goes okay i just
need to breathe keep my composure keep
on pot
shot in this guy then landing heavy when
i can but just go to a decision
obviously they stopped this which i
thought was kind of unfair to chris
moutinho like you let the guy take a
beating for 14 and a half minutes and
then
you give him 30 seconds right where he's
it's kind of like disrespectful like
yeah
but um but i thought it was really cool
he went through this right now
that's going to be super valuable
because you don't want to go through
that in the second round of a title
fight with the entire world watching you
yeah where you go oh my god i can't
knock them out i can't sleep this guy
right what do i what else do i have yeah
that was
my cardio on point like yeah but it was
a cool fight though yeah and like
respect to the dude for coming on short
notice
that was part of the night and they each
got an extra 75k
yeah because it was ufc fighting i mean
i love it what happens to that guy chris
messina oh he's on the roster like
everybody's interested in him
yeah everybody wants to see him again
and i think what you do with him if i'm
if i'm dana white is i start building
them up
like i don't leave him there as a human
punching bag i go
okay you he fought quite possibly the
worst person that he could fight
an incredibly skilled striker yeah
imagine he fought a guy
who wasn't a skilled striker but just
someone who's there to bang
and that guy isn't going down now
they're just slogan so now they're just
like this guy can be a like a favorite
you know like a donald cerrone type or
something like
he can be a journeyman if you will but
a guy who makes tons of money on that
journey having incredibly
exciting wars yeah so build them up
against guys who are a little bit
lower ranked and not you know sean
o'malley i mean they have title
aspirations for sean o'malley i'm sure
yeah like let chris build himself up in
the same way that shawn built himself up
you know like sean o'malley i don't
think i don't think the first guys that
he was fighting were ranked fighters
no so i'm excited for that guy i think
nothing went down in that guy's stock at
all
no i mean way up and i think that the
ufc is really cool in terms of like
they reward entertainment if you're
entertaining [ __ ] out there
even if you lose
you're to be ready to fight again yeah i
feel like the loser in the fight of the
night
will get more credit than like just a
low card winner 100 percent
even gilbert burns beating wonder boy
it's boring it's like you're just gonna
lay on top of them the whole [ __ ]
time like
[Music]
sucks like i don't care i don't want to
watch it boring whack yeah
like don't care move on
strike i know you don't want to strike
with wonder boy because he's so good at
but like
if we want to entertain us you want to
get the big bucks that's not how you get
a title fight
right the way you get title fight is be
entertaining as [ __ ] yeah
like and i think what's cool is if if
whatever you reward
the fighters will do right so if you
know that the way that you get a title
fight is by knocking a [ __ ] out
yeah we'll go for knockouts yeah i'll
dye my hair green dye my hair cream i'll
get in there do whatever whatever i
gotta do
i mean speaking entertainment you saw
trump pulled up ringside son
whoa boys going full cent yeah
leaning fully into trump but they've
always been full maggot though
yeah they're not was they're like they
were at the what do you call it the
rally or whatever yeah they were on air
force one full magic canadians yeah but
they're canadians which is so funny
yeah i think i mean i kind of get it
from their perspective it's like kind of
voyeurism
yes yeah i mean like you just want the
guy that's stirring the most [ __ ] up
because that's what they do right they
start [ __ ] up so like yeah
whatever yeah i don't even know who the
knock boys are i'm gonna be honest
about them out of it guys need to tap
back into culture bro
he's been in like a time capsule i know
what's going on this is idiocracy oh
yeah
guys just came back no i'm i'm with you
i the only thing one of the guys is the
one he goes like
huh behind people that [ __ ]
that's that's the only thing i know
about that guy
behind people in the grocery store yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah
he's one of the boys that [ __ ] with it
and then there's like the main dude i
think his name is steve
yeah steve will do it i don't even know
what he does he i know he'll do it he
will do it but i don't know what he does
whatever it is
i only know saleem [ __ ] cause cause
moaning at people at shifty's old job
these old jobs
[Laughter]
and just seeing their reactions you saw
shifty doing it and that's where you got
the idea
no but they're legends like content nah
they know what they're doing yeah and
they
teamed up with trump right he's at
ringside with uh another legend of
content if we're being honest
we can allow ourselves that you think
trump's uh running again
he must be has to be why else is he in
public all the time like why else is he
like doing all these rallies and
he spoke at cpac cpac they said that
like uh
loki terrifying with 95 certainty he
would win the
republican republican primary it's
really trump's party dude
it is that whole like oh it's the
republican party is a party of trump and
everyone was like nah
nah it'll switch back it's so much
trump's party that republicans still
haven't left him
like they still are they're still heavy
trump people
normally they just support whoever's in
power whoever gets the job done whoever
they think can win
republicans play to win you can agree or
disagree with what they're doing
democrats play to do what's right
republicans are like nah we just want to
[Applause]
win
you